Jurassic world is back in a huge way
with new dinosaurs baby blue and Ian
Malcolm himself in the first full
trailer for fallen Kingdom yippee-ki-yay
movie lovers it's Jan here and today I'm
breaking down the Jurassic world 2
trailer for Easter eggs things you
missed and explaining the new dinosaurs
you can look forward to in the movie and
if you're new to my channel I do movie
breakdowns Easter eggs deleted scenes
and moviemaking secrets as well as
regular giveaways for all my subscribers
for my current giveaway just make sure
you're subscribed and leave me a comment
on this video with your thoughts about
fallen Kingdom I'll have more details on
that plus the winner of my last giveaway
later in the video the trailer begins
with Owen and Claire who are setting up
a task force to save the dinosaurs left
on the island from a dormant volcano
about to explode
Claire is putting together a new
organization called the dinosaur
protection group and in the trailer we
get a glimpse of some of the group's
other key members we've got a new young
scientist played by justice Smith and
it's rumoured he's playing a character
inspired by RB Benton from author
Michael Crichton's second Jurassic Park
novel in another shot we get a glimpse
of Ted Levine's character who seems to
be dressed in combat gear and behind him
is Daniella Panetta's character we don't
yet have names for their characters but
in a picture of Pineda released in a
behind-the-scenes trailer reel you can
see she's got a tattoo which partially
reads Semper Fi which is the US Marine
Corps motto meaning she's likely either
from the US military or she's a former
Marine we then get to the island where
it's clear that since the events of
Jurassic world the theme park is more or
less in ruins and dinosaurs are roaming
freely by the way the official synopsis
states that sequel has actually set four
years after the first Jurassic world
movie and back from Jurassic world is
our favorite Raptor Blu who at the end
of that movie disappeared into the
jungle after helping Rexy defeat the
indominus also in this next shot of blue
reuniting with owen there's an abandoned
old Explorer from the original Jurassic
Park movie in the background earlier in
the trailer there was also an adorable
short scene of Owen with baby blue we
don't know yet where this comes in the
film however I think this might be some
old video of her in raising baby blue
and imprinting on her which he talked
about doing in Jurassic world and I
think this footage might get played if
Owen gives testimony at this committee
meeting where we seen on other
Ian Malcolm himself now we did get some
Ian Malcolm Easter eggs in Jurassic
world but this is the moment a lot of
fans of the franchise have been waiting
for and of course Jeff Goldblum even
gets to deliver his classic line life
finds away he's in what looks like a US
government Senate hearing or a courtroom
and I imagine he's been called upon as
an expert witness presumably to comment
on the events of Jurassic world or
perhaps to advise what to do about the
dinosaurs still at large uh nice line
new blood that seems rather ironic
because in the original movies where
Malcolm tried to tell the public about
what happened at Jurassic Park
he was discredited by John Hammonds
nephew made a laughingstock and his
career was ruined we don't yet know from
the limited lines we here in the trailer
whether Malcolm is for or against saving
the dinos on the island although this is
the only scene we've seen of him so far
I'm hoping we see him pop up at least
once again though he might just have a
small role appearing near the start and
end of the movie like John Hammond did
in the lost world okay let's get back to
the island where we're going to see some
of the new dinosaurs and some more
callbacks to the original Jurassic Park
when we see Claire and her crew hiding
behind some tree trunks from a herd of
charging dinos it's an homage to that
memorable scene in the first Jurassic
Park movie of dr. Grant and the children
hiding behind a tree trunk to avoid a
dinosaur stampede and just at this
moment we get our first look at the
Carnotaurus a new dinosaur for the
sequel the Carnotaurus which means
meat-eating both has two horns above its
eyes and fun fact genetic material from
the Carnotaurus was used for the
creation of the hybrid indominus rex in
the first Jurassic world now this is one
pretty mean-looking Dino but just as it
seems to be about to take out Owen and
the others Rexy swoops in and saves the
day and if you're thinking there seems
to be something familiar about this
scene it's because it's clearly a
tribute to the final scene in Jurassic
Park where the t-rex roars after saving
the adults and kids from the
velociraptors another new dinosaur which
was only hinted at in Jurassic world but
which we were getting properly in fallen
kingdom is the Baryonyx the name refers
to the heavy large claw on the dinos
first finger and it was going to be the
original primary antagonist in the third
Jurassic Park movie until it was
replaced by the Spinosaurus and it looks
like the Baryonyx will make a
spectacular appearance during an
underground
seen in what is probably a control room
for an old power plant on the island you
can see fire and lava flowing so it
looks like this scene takes place around
the time the volcano begins to erupt we
know now that Rexy is back for the
sequel and in another shot we can see
she's been sedated and loaded into a
truck and although we see what looks
like a lot of dinosaurs probably
perishing from the volcano eruption
there are a few shots earlier in the
trailer that show what looks like a boat
loaded with dinosaurs leaving the island
now if you're concerned you've seen most
of the movie's plot rest assured that
these scenes are actually only from the
first half of the movie and are in a
sense a setup for the main plot of the
film the official synopsis has actually
stated that Claire and Owen uncover a
conspiracy that could return our entire
planet to a perilous order not seen
since prehistoric times which means I
think that there's a plot going on to
bring these dinosaurs off the island and
to the mainland in gem will likely be
involved in this together with Henry Wu
who we didn't get to see in this trailer
dr. Wu was last seen in Jurassic world
on an engine helicopter making off with
a bunch of dinosaur DNA from the park
however in the fallen kingdom behind the
scenes real we did get a brief glimpse
of woo-hoos definitely cooking up a new
hybrid the endo Raptor which I expect
we'll see later in the film by the way
all the footage released so far suggests
were getting a much bigger push for
animatronic dinosaurs in fallen Kingdom
practical effects were a big part of the
original Jurassic Park movie whereas the
first Jurassic world movie only used
animatronics in a single scene with a
dying Apatosaurus the animatronics
development on the sequel has been
spearheaded by Neal Scanlan whose
creature designs you'll have seen in the
new Star Wars movies animatronics will
be limited mostly to close-up shots with
CGI enhancing some elements but from
what's been teased so far it looks good
now what did you think of the first full
trailer for fallen Kingdom where you're
a fan of the first movie and has the
trailer got you hyped for the new sequel
let me know what you think for chance to
win a cool Funko pop make sure you leave
a comment below about the trailer and
subscribe to my channel the winner of my
recent giveaway is on screen now and if
that's you make sure you send me a
private message with your details so I
can get the prize out to you and if you
enjoyed this I really appreciate you
hitting that like button and don't
forget to turn on those
occasions to get all my new videos plus
you can check out some more videos
you're sure to LIKE here thanks for
watching and see you next time you
became movie lovers